well we all need a reason to wake up for
me it just took eleven thousand volts I
know you're too polite to ask so I will
tell you one night sophomore year of
college just back from Thanksgiving
holiday a few of my friends and I were
horsing around we decided to climb atop
a part commuter train it's just sitting
there with the wires that run overhead
somehow that seemed like a great idea at
the time we'd certainly done stupider
things I scurried up the ladder on the
back and when I stood up the electrical
current entered my arm blew down and out
my feet and that was that would you
believe that watch still works takes a
lickin my father wears it now in
solidarity that night began my formal
relationship with death my death and it
also began my long run as a patient too
good word means one who suffers like us
for all patients now the American
healthcare system has more than its fair
share of dysfunction to match its
brilliance to be sure I'm a physician
now a hospice and palliative medicine
doc so I've seen care from both sides
and believe me most everyone who goes
into healthcare really means well I mean
truly but we who work in it are also
unwitting agents for a system that too
often does not serve why well there's
actually a pretty easy answer that
question and it explains a lot because
health care was designed with
diseases not people at its center which
is to say of course it was badly
designed and nowhere are the effects of
bad design more heartbreaking or the
opportunity for good design more
compelling than at the end of life where
things are so distilled and concentrated
there's no do-overs my purpose today is
to reach out across disciplines and
invite design thinking into this big
conversation that is to bring intention
and creativity to the experience of
dying we have a monumental opportunity
in front of us before a universal one of
the few Universal issues as individuals
as well as a civil society to rethink
and redesign how it is we die so let's
begin at the end for most people the
scariest thing about death isn't being
dead it's dimed suffering it's a key
distinction and to get underneath of
this it can be very helpful to tease out
suffering which is necessary as it is
from suffering we can change the former
is a natural essential part of life part
of the deal and to this we are called to
make space but just grow it can be
really good to realize forces larger
than ourselves
they bring proportionality like a cosmic
right-sizing after my limbs were gone
that loss for example became fact fixed
necessarily part of my life and I
learned I could no more reject this fact
than reject myself
took me a while but I'd learned it
eventually now another great thing about
necessary suffering is that it is the
very thing that unites caregiver and
care receiver human beings this we are
finally realizing is where healing
happens yes compassion literally as we
learned yesterday suffering together now
on the system's side on the other hand
so much of the suffering is unnecessary
invented serves no good purpose but the
good news is since this brand of
suffering is made up well we can change
it how we die is indeed something we can
affect now making the system sensitive
to this fundamental distinction between
necessary and unnecessary suffering
gives us our first of three design cues
for the day after all our role as
caregivers as people who care is to
relieve suffering not add to the pile
true to the tenets of palliative care I
function as something of a reflective
advocate as much as a prescribing
physician quick aside palliative care
very important field but poorly
understood while it includes it is not
limited to end-of-life care it is not
limited to hospice it's simply about
comfort and living well at any stage ok
so please know that you don't have to be
dying anytime soon to benefit from
palliative care now let me introduce you
to Frank sort of makes this point I've
been seeing Frank now for years he's
living with advancing prostate cancer on
top of long-standing HIV we work on his
bone pain and his fatigue but most of
the time we spend thinking out loud
together about his life really about our
lives in this way Frank grieves this way
he keeps up with his losses as
roll in so that he's ready to take in
the next moment loss is one thing regret
quite another
so Frank has always been an adventurer
looks like something out of a Norman
Rockwell painting and no fan of regret
so it wasn't surprising when he came
into clinic one day saying he wanted to
raft down the Colorado River was this a
good idea no with all the risks to his
safety and his health some would say no
many did but he went for it while he
still could and it was glorious
marvelous trip freezing water
blistering dry heat scorpions snakes
wildlife howling off of the flaming
walls of the Grand Canyon all the
glorious side of the world beyond our
control now Frank's decision while maybe
dramatic is exactly the kind so many of
us would make if we only had the support
to figure out what is best for ourselves
over time so much of what we're talking
about today is a shift in perspective
after my accident when I went back to
college I changed my major to art
history studying visual art I figured
I'd learned something about how to see a
really potent lesson for a kid who
couldn't change so much of what he was
seeing perspective that kind of alchemy
we humans get to play with turning
anguish into a flower
flash-forward now I work at an amazing
place in San Francisco called the Zen
hospice project where we have a little
ritual that helps with this shift in
perspective when one of our residents
dies the mortuary men come and as we're
wheeling the body out through the garden
headed for the gate we pause anyone who
wants fellow residents family nurses
volunteers the hearse drivers to now
share a story or a song or silence
as we sprinkle the body with flower
petals takes a few minutes the sweet
simple parting image to usher in grief
with warmth rather than repugnance
contrast that with the typical
experience in the hospital setting much
like this floodlit room lined with tubes
and beeping machines and blinking lights
that don't stop even when the patient's
life has cleaning crews swoops in the
bodies whisked away it's all it feels as
though that person had never really
existed well-intended of course in the
name of sterility but hospitals tend to
assault our senses and the most we might
hope for within those walls is numbness
anesthetic literally the opposite of
aesthetic I revere hospitals for what
they can do I am Alive because of them
but we ask too much of our hospitals
they are places for acute trauma and
treatable illness there no place to live
and die that's not what they were
designed for now mind you I'm not giving
up on the notion that our institutions
you become more humane Beauty can be
found anywhere I spent a few months in a
burn unit at st. Barnabas Hospital in
Livingston New Jersey where I got really
great care at every turn including good
palliative care for my pain and one
night it began to snow outside I
remember I remember my nurses
complaining about driving through it and
there was no window in my room but it
was great to just imagine it coming down
all sticky next day one of my nurses
smuggled in a snowball for me she
brought it into the unit I cannot tell
you the rapture I felt holding that in
my hand
now the coldness dripping onto my
burning skin the miracle of it all the
fascination as I watched it melt and
turn into water in that moment just
being any part of this planet in this
universe mattered more to me than
whether I lived or died that little
snowball packed all the inspiration I
needed to both try to live and be okay
if I did not in a hospital that's a
stolen moment in my work over the years
I've known many people who were ready to
go ready to die and not because they had
found some final piece or transcendence
but because they were so repulsed by
what their lives had become in a word
cut off or ugly there are already record
numbers of us living with chronic and
terminal illness and into ever older age
and we are nowhere near ready or
prepared for this silver tsunami we need
an infrastructure dynamic enough to
handle these seismic shifts in our
population now is a time to create
something new something vital I know we
can because we have to the alternative
is just unacceptable and the key
ingredients are known policy education
and training systems bricks and mortar
we have tons of input for designers of
all stripes to work with we know for
example from research what's most
important to people who are closer to
death comfort feeling unburdened and
unburdening to those they love
existential peace and a sense of
wonderment in spirituality
over Zen hospices nearly 30 years we've
learned much more from our residents in
subtle detail little things aren't so
little take Janette she finds it harder
to breathe one day to the next due to
ALS well guess what
she wants to start smoking again and
French cigarettes if you please not out
of some self-destructive bent but to
feel her lungs filled while she has them
priorities change
or Kate she just wants to know her dog
Austen is lying at the foot of her bed
his cold muzzle against her dry skin
instead of more chemotherapy coursing
through her veins she's done that
sensuous aesthetic gratification we're
in a moment in an instant we are
rewarded for just being so much of it
comes down to loving our time by way of
the senses by way of the body the very
thing doing the living and the dying
probably the most poignant room in the
Zen Hospice guesthouse is our kitchen
which is a little strange when you
realize that so many of our residents
can eat very little if anything at all
but we realize we are providing
sustenance on several levels smell
symbolic plane seriously with all the
heavy-duty stuff happening under our
roof one of the most tried and trued
interventions we know of is to bake
cookies
as long as we have our senses even just
one we have at least the possibility of
accessing what makes us feel human
connected you know imagine the ripples
of this notion for the millions of
people living and dying with dementia
primal sensorial delights but say the
things we don't have words for impulses
that make us stay present no need for a
past or a future
so if teasing unnecessary suffering out
of the system was our first design cue
hmm then tending to dignity by way of
the census by way of the body the
aesthetic realm is designed cue number
two now this gets us quickly to the
third and final bid for today namely we
need to lift our sights to set our
sights on well-being that life can
become and health and healthcare can
become about making life more wonderful
rather than just less horrible
beneficence here this gets right at the
distinction between a disease centered
and a patient or human centered model of
care and here is where caring becomes a
creative generative even playful act
play may sound like a funny word here
but it's also in our highest forms of
adaptation consider every major
compulsory effort it takes to be human
the need for food is earth cuisine need
for shelters given rise to architecture
the need for cover fashion and for being
subjected to the clock
well we invented music so since dying is
a necessary part of life what might we
create with this fad by play I am in no
way suggesting we take a light approach
to dying or that we mandate any
particular way of dying there are
mountains of sorrow that can
move and one way or another we will all
kneel there rather I am asking we make
space physical psychic room to allow
life to play itself all the way out so
that rather than just getting out of the
way aging and dying can become a process
of crescendo through to the end we can't
we can't solve four deaths I know some
of you are working on this meanwhile we
can we can design towards it now parts
of me died early on and that's something
we can all say one way or another I got
to redesign my life around this fact and
I tell you it has been a liberation to
realize you can always find a shock of
beauty or meaning in what life you have
left like that snowball lasting for a
perfect moment all the while melting
away
if we love such moments ferociously but
then maybe we can learn to live well not
in spite of death but because of it let
death be what takes us not lack of
imagination
[Applause]